jours à tous bon show richard ramos
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
modem particulièrement investie pour la
défense des consommateurs et dans la
lutte contre la malbouffe et si vous
êtes là ce matin ce parce que vous êtes
en colère en colère contre les hausses
des prix vous demandez tout simplement
une commission d' enquête parlementaire
sur l'inflation pourquoi c'est simple
aujourd'hui quand vous allez dans votre
supermarché vous avez des prix qu'on
flamber et on se dit mais est-ce que ça
a à voir avec l'ukraine par exemple il
vient par exemple sur les pattes on a
des prix des pâtes et puis c'est pas du
blessé du blé dur et donc le blé dur il
n'a pas été fait en ukraine et donc on
se dit mais pourquoi ça augmente
pourquoi j'ai des produits notamment le
coca cola qui augmente et donc je veux
savoir pourquoi et mois avant les
élections qu'avant la crise actuelle
j'avais déjà demandé une caution dans
quête sur le juste prix c'est quoi
aujourd'hui à juste prix dans le
supermarché et donc il faut absolument
que le parlement se saisisse de ça pour
que les français quand ils vont au
supermarché il achète le juste prix
alors bruno le maire de nice de
l'économie et des finances a annoncé
qu'ils avaient une mission qui était
confiée à l'inspection générale des
finances justement pour se pencher sur
cette hausse des prix c'est satisfaisant
ou pas oui ça ça va être son travail au
ministère nous au parlement on a déjà la
commission des affaires économiques sous
la houlette du président casbah riant on
a déjà pris la main pour aller regarder
de près ce qui s'y passe derrière ses
prix est-ce qu'il y en a pas qui sont en
train de faire du pognon sur le dos des
français ayant justement pour vous
derrière ces hausses de prix parfois
injustifiées d'après vous il ya quoi
alors il ya plusieurs choses vous avez
des grosses compagnies maritimes qui
sont sur 5 6 dans le monde qui bloque
dans les ports les produits comme ça ça
crée un manque et le manque ça fait
flamber le prix ça c'est la première des
choses la deuxième des choses il faut
regarder évidemment le prix mais
attention on à michel edouard leclerc
qui sur tous les plateaux avec son
talent habituel nous a expliqué s'armer
en même temps envoyé michel edouard
leclerc je vous arrête qui dit que la
moitié selon lui des hausses de prix
demandées par les industriels de
l'agroalimentaire ne sont pas
transparents et suspecte il a raison non
il n'a pas raison sur ils exagèrent
c'est pas la moitié vous avez à peu près
je pense nous on va regarder c'est ce
que c'est ça qu'il faut regarder de très
près je pense 20% mais le problème avec
michel edouard leclerc et je dois le
dire en ce moment intermarché est encore
pire que lui ils sont en train
d'étrangler vous entendez bien étranglé
nos petites pme et nos paysans dans les
boxes de négociations comment parce que
en leur mettant des pénalités logistique
qui n'existe pas c'est à dire que vous
vous êtes un petit pme françaises vous
allez fabriquer un produit mais vous
avez des problèmes avec le carton avec
la livraison carton mais vous allez
quand même essayer de livrer votre
supermarché et bien si vous avez du
retard on va vous mettre des pénalités
logistique de transport on va dire à 20%
des produits livrés alors qu'ils en ont
encore dans le rayon donc ça veut dire
que supermarché il n'a pas eu de
préjudice commercial puisque le produit
est encore dans le rayon mais nos
petites pme elle qu'est ce qu'elles vont
faire on va leur mettre 20 % de pénalité
c'est une honte et qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait la pme quand elle a pris 20% de
pénalité la fois d'après quand elle
livre elle intègre ses 20% pénalité dans
son prix et donc c'est bien michel
edouard leclerc et en ce moment encore
plus intermarché qui font monter les
prix parce que aujourd'hui ils sont en
train de se servir de sa également pour
essorer nos pme alors évidemment il
voulait de la promotion pourquoi parce
qu'ils vont aller travailler avec les
industriels les multinationales comme ça
ces gens là vont pouvoir avec des
compensations international faire des
prix bas et ce sera au détriment des
emplois des français donc je dis
attention français vous êtes des
consommateurs mais vous êtes aussi les
salariés et si on achète rayon brad et
qu'on fait de la promotion ils iront
acheter avec des multinationales et vos
boutiques fermeront est ce que cette
hausse des prix a des conséquences oui
ou non sur la qualité des produits oui
ah oui c'est très important ce que vous
ne dites là ça veut dire que aujourd'hui
puisque les supermarchés pour être le
zorro de 2,0 inflation est souvent sous
le couvert de bercy qui dit comme je
veux pas l'inflation je vais défendre
les supermarchés je vais défendre les
michel edouard leclerc et consorts il ya
qu'est-ce qui se passe ça veut dire que
l'industriel qui lui est étranglé par le
prix quand il peut plus faire de prix
bas qu'est ce qui fait il change sa
recette et qu'est ce qu'on fait on remet
du sucre on remet du gras on leur met du
sel ça c'est ce que vous dites est
extrêmement grave vous avez des preuves
mais quand les uns de mes billets mais
des changes les compositions du produit
mais bien évidemment qu'on a des preuves
et et et ap moi ça fait des années que
je travaille avec les industriels qui
est-ce qui mal qui m'a alerté ce sont
les pme qui m'ont dit monsieur ramos
monsieur le député si nous on peut pas
livrer parce que ils veulent pas prendre
une hausse de prix est bien qu'est ce
qu'on va faire on va c'est la recette
vous allez c'est cette traditionnelle
dans la grande distribution ça change je
crois un exemple on est le matin ici on
apprend le nesquik vous prenez le
district du matin vous prenez sur 10 ans
ce qui a dans le nesquik et bien sûr dix
ans vous verrez que le taux de cacao
dans le nesquik et bien il a baissé
parce que comme il ya des guerres de
prix on baisse la qualité la tablette de
chocolat encore le groupe nestlé
international vous avez cette fameuse
tablette de chocolat pour vers la mousse
au chocolat la fameux nestlé dessert eh
bien vous verrez elle elle n'a pas
baissé en qualité mais par contre pour
le même prix vous avez moins de
grammages elle est plus petit que votre
tablette alors c'est ça avec les autres
parlementaires sur lequel vous souhaitez
vous penchez d'extrêmement près pour
voir s'il ya matière ou pas à demander
évidemment aussi des sanctions c'est une
problème évidemment pour la qualité des
produits un problème pour le
portefeuille des français et je crois
vous dites aussi un risque de
discrimination alimentaire quasiment ça
veut dire quoi et oui vous avez vu par
exemple michel edouard lequel nous a dit
que ces prix écho plus dans un
supermarché leclerc les prix les plus
bas ça s'appelle et qu'aucun si sûr
beaucoup d'autres y voient la rochelle
pendant je prends suis là parce que
c'est l'exemple que que j'ai en tête
donc tous les prix bas mais les hardes
'hard discount' avait très très presque
disparu en france on avait réussi en
cinq ans à faire en sorte que on aille
acheter des produits de plus grande
qualité aujourd'hui les échos plus ces
compagnies sont en train d'augmenter et
donc ça veut dire qu on est en train de
revenir pour les consommateurs les plus
pauvres sur des produits à moindre
valeur ça veut dire qu'on est en train
de fabriquer 2 2 types d'alimentation
c'est à dire une pour les riches
corrélés même se le payer et les po ur
vous retournez sur les produits hard
discount qui sont pas les mêmes valeurs
nutritionnelles et donc ça veut dire
qu'on est en train de fabriquer une
alimentation pour les pauvres d'un côté
et pour les bobos que nous sommes de
l'autre côté et on le sait la courbe de
l'obésité par exemple suit la cour de la
pauvreté plus vous achetez un produit
qui est peu cher plus vous avez du sucre
du gras et du sel dedans et donc ça veut
dire que pendant cette période de vide
c'était les gens les plus obèses donc
les plus pauvres qui ont été les plus
fragiles et donc on est en train de
fabriquer deux alimentations en france
et le combat de ma vie c'est qu'ils
aient pas deux alimentations en france
même les pauvres ont le droit de manger
de passe en scène richard allemand je
disais vous êtes député modem donc dans
la majorité d'ici quelques jours
quelques semaines ya le projet de loi
sur le pouvoir d'achat qui va arriver à
l'assemblée nationale ya notamment
chèques alimentaires qui est prévu par
le gouvernement 100 euros pour 9
millions de foyers les plus modestes
plus 50 euros pour enfants vous avez
signé une tribune qui demande à ce que
ce chèque alimentaires ils soient
ciblées sur les produits
particulièrement sain concrètement
comment on fait bien pour moi c'est
simple on va prendre une carte bleue on
va là crédité et on va envoyer aux
étudiants aux eaux aux personnes vous
les petits revenus cette carte bleue qui
va être crédité d'un certain montant et
avec ce montant là avec cette carte
bleue là vous allez pouvoir acheter des
produits qui sont des produits non ultra
transformé ça veut dire que moi je veux
qu'on puisse acheter des produits sains
non ultra transformer on aura un autre
avantage pour nos paysans français c'est
que comme on aura exclus et les produits
ultra transformer ces les seuls produits
qui n'ont pas obligation de dire
l'origine des produits qui les composent
et donc ça veut dire qu'on re flèche de
bien manger pour les plus humbles et les
produits français et ça aujourd'hui
c'est mon combat et c'est mon combat
pour le consommateur votre autre combat
aussi c'est votre combat pour interdire
les nitrites notamment dans la
charcuterie ces additifs qui permettent
de mieux conserver la charcuterie de la
rendre un peu plus joli aux yeux des des
consommateurs l' agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire la semaine prochaine
doit rendre un rapport sur la toxicité
justement de ces additifs est ce que
vous avez pu avoir accès à ce rapport
est ce que vous demandez toujours
l'interdiction de ces nitrites alors
bien évidemment que je demande
l'interdiction de ces nitrites et puis
sur cette antenne on peut rendre hommage
à axel kahn qui était ce généticien et
qui était présent de la ligue contre le
cancer décédé il ya quasiment à date à
date il ya un an et qui avec moi à
accompagner à faire là c'est simple les
industriels certains maîtres du nitrite
dans la charcuterie pour par exemple
quelle est la couleur rose mais quand
vous allez chez votre charcutier vous
demandez pas du jambon rose vous
demandez du jambon blanc ça veut bien
dire qu'il était blanc le jambon on a
mis du rose parce que ça retient de
l'eau parce que tu as et que connat
d'abord ce rapport il va dire un truc
incroyable
il ya eu quelques fuites évidemment
comme d'habitude il va reconnaître pour
la première fois que le nitrite ça q que
le nitrite quand on en mange dans la
charcuterie dans la charcuterie je dis
bien eh bien vous avez un risque de
cancer colorectal et ce rapport il va
dire oui il ya un lien entre cancer
colorectal et nitrites dans la
charcuterie il va le dire ce rapport
clairement et donc je vais dire au
ministre il faut l'interdire c'est 5000
morts par an entre quatre et cinq mille
morts par an en france vous êtes rares
déposé une proposition de loi
proposition de loi travailler avec
l'excellent ministre marc fesneau j'aime
du modem également les modèles mais oui
mais je n'ai aucun doute aujourd'hui le
rapport devrait dire qu'il ya un bien
que colas zee il ya un lien de causalité
entre cancer colorectal
cinq mille morts par an en france et
aujourd'hui ni tri dans la charcuterie
je n'ai aucun doute que le ministre
protégera le consommateur merci beaucoup
richard ramos d'être venu avec nous ce
matin partager votre coup de gueule pour
la défense des consommateurs